good to see you agency buddy good to see
you how you doing I'm doing fine you
know I'm feeling good it's good I'm
feeling good about myself because I've
been pounding the Rich Eisen show desk
on both coasts now I see that about
about the issue that baseball needs to
deal with is not pace of play but style
of play quality of play yeah and the
commissioner who's been mr. father time
you know happiness watch looking at
everybody saying let's let's go let's
pick up the pace here a came on and he
just said I'm not worried about time a
game doesn't is worried but it's about
pace of play I've never heard him say
that before is that a new thing that we
just heard well yeah I think it's new
but I here's what I think is new they're
still definitely interested in the pace
of play because they want you to get in
and out within three hours sir but I
think the revelation for the
Commissioner and I think everybody in
the in the front office over there
it may not be revelation it might be a
stronger word is the fact that the ball
is not in play and this is something
that's been discussed for a while that's
why you hear so much conversation about
a Pitts clock and the shift being taken
away putting regulations in because it's
gonna create more activity and the three
true outcomes strikeout walk homer are
happening and it's not good for the game
right now so that's why the Commissioner
I think he's one he's a fan he watches
the every game and if you watch every
game like he does he's not blind he sees
what's happening so yeah it was
refreshing to hear that I was I think he
but he knows that he finally put it out
there for everybody to know he knows
okay great so is the shift the biggest
culprit way that I'm targeting yeah I
think it probably is I think everything
kind of trickles down from that what was
the last time you saw hit and run a
double steal all those things and and
that to me comes from the front office's
so it's a combination this shift has the
face on it but I think if you look at
the general managers all seeing the game
the same way right for a guy who's been
around as long as I have and you've
probably heard this hey that's how the
Orioles play oh that guy must be a
Royals player oh he plays today's
there's no team identity it's just
they all play the same style and that's
why the shift to me has changed the game
well walk me through it before we get
into a little bit more on the field so
more often than not what what is it that
do the general managers in Major League
Baseball make the Rost make the lineups
more so yeah managers they basically say
okay we know who's pitching and these
are the guys that we think are armed
just against this pitcher and give that
line up to the manager and say this is
who you're starting and then the manager
just has to actually manage the game
once the once the yeah there's only a
few managers I think left in baseball
that go here's the lineup I'm suggesting
you suggest lamp to me here's where I'm
writing it out I think they all now are
written out basically by the front
office so yes yes did you ever have a
manager who had that happen when you
play now when I played no manager
controlled everything and that's what
we're seeing different is that I played
four managers that were defensive minded
or they were offensive minded there was
creativity you knew what the style was
the lineups now players get a text
message in the morning you're playing
tonight rich I know you hit two home
runs yesterday mr. joc pederson but
you're not in the lineup you know that's
what they get now that's the message in
the morning to let us know if you're in
the game or not if you're not so
everyone gets a text message yes you're
out today or you're in today and it's
easy to have somebody not come back at
you like hey hold it timeout I'm hotter
than a pistol why am I not playing it's
a it's an arms away distance that I just
suit your text and there's no no
conversation no confrontation until I
guess maybe you see him at the ballpark
but by then you're off yeah probably so
which manager that you played for would
have least liked to have heard from the
front office that is your line up to the
hands down dick Williams I mean I got so
many Dick Williams stories I can't even
begin to imagine what he would do today
with with a lineup being handed to him
but I do think this he would have taken
the information yes I think the
information is great you know this guy
is gonna hit the ball here 90% of the
time this guy is going to do this this
matchup there but at the end of the day
there is a human element and I think the
one thing that dick Williams knew was
yeah the numbers might say this guy's
good but he's terrible he has no heart
he's gonna fold in the seventh you know
that's that would have been dick
Williams and so I think that's the
difference well I mean how how Reynolds
here in the Rich Eisen show and again
you can watch him on MLB tonight airs
seven days a week Emmy nominated again
plus MLB Network is airing live baseball
every day for the rest of April
including tonight's Athletics Astros
game at 8:00 Eastern Time it's a good
matchup right there how predictive are
metrics I mean how accurately predictive
are these metrics they're fairly
accurate and and the thing is I think
the players have played into it
they haven't made an adjustment I can't
I can't imagine going to the plate and
having five guys on one side of the
field and not think about hitting the
ball the other way
it doesn't enter players minds and so to
me what's happening is you're getting
paid on the statistics now that
everybody thinks is important war on
base percentage RBI not RBIs they don't
think RBIs and batting average matter so
they're throwing those two things out
possible in my history of the most
determinative factor is runs yes I'm
just telling you more runs than the
other team you win yes I hate this
that's my point you would see it
differently if you're a general manager
and I might see the game differently
than somebody else what we have is it
almost so a think tank they'll see the
game the same RBIs don't matter batting
averages of as of luck it's a product of
luck individual pitching is what an
individual can control those are the
things that that most front officers are
looking at so it's frustrating because
you don't end the game unless somebody
scores right somebody's got a drive in
and run and not everybody that walks is
going to score from first base on a ball
hitting the gap so we're at a crossroads
trying to figure all these things out
right now Harold Reynolds here on the
Rich Eisen show Astra's are playing
tonight and that's one way I can walk
through this door here how why why
doesn't Dallas
I'll have a job right now how is that
possible well one I don't know what
offers he's had so he's had offers it
may not be for so number one it may not
be what he thinks he's worth or where he
thinks the markets at it's not like he
hasn't had an offer so I don't know what
that is
secondly it may not be what he wants
obviously is not hasn't got what he
wants opportunist and why would Dallas
Keuchel not get an offer that you as a
former player would understand that he
would take well again I think what we're
seeing is you asked me earlier how
accurate are the the numbers and a lot
of front office's believe the act the
numbers are 100 percent so if you're
watching the trends in baseball over the
last two or three years if you're 31 or
32 they're basically saying now you're
dropping off I'm not paying for the rest
of those years I play for your prime
years that's why you're seeing trout
Harper Machado those guys get long
extend the contracts because they want
to pay for those prime years so pitchers
are being viewed like running backs in
football right now once you hit 30 or
play or two players players in general
really that's that's really if you look
at the crux of it you look at Adam Jones
Adam Jones 333 years old you think he's
40 the way we acted this winter and he's
still a very productive player but he's
not gonna have those prime years ahead
of him so here's where you're at and I
think it's a combination of things
there are a lot of players in the big
leagues that shouldn't be you know they
shouldn't be there and they paid for
mediocrity for a long period of time so
because of skies that shouldn't be there
and some contracts that haven't worked
everybody pays for that so now they've
mainstreamed it - we know these are the
prime years of a player I'll gladly pay
I'll overpay for those but if you're
before or after they're not paying for
that
why are players that don't belong in the
league are they in Lake they're like
they're well if you live or something
like that or they're well I'm not even
rule 5 is it's to me it's how the
lineups rosters constructed if you can
take for the Cubs for example or the
Milwaukee Brewers and put Moustakas or
bode at second base why do I need to
carry that a little second base where
that could have some range
I didn't put my third baseman in that
second and put him in right field and a
shift that's why I've become an advocate
against the shift
there's no athleticism anymore and we're
cutting the little guy out if there's my
frustration being the little guy that
played yes and the great thing about
baseball we've always said size doesn't
matter but now we're talking about exit
velocity and all these different things
if you don't hit a ball over a 95 mile
an hour exit velocity you're not
considered a very good player well how
can that be if I drop down a base hit
and still second and third that's pretty
good yeah but those don't compute so yes
I'm Sasha figuring all out Seinfeld
line when we interviewed him about the
beauty of baseball he says it's the
democracy of talent and physique that
you can have no I like that you can have
it's what he said it's it doesn't matter
if you're five sticks if you're Altuve
or judge yeah those were there too MVP
candidates obviously Altuve what couple
years ago but that's the beauty of
baseball it's a democracy of talent and
physique yeah and you're saying right
now though that the the metrics are
messing with that the metrics are
screwing that around a little bit yes
but I will say this yes the game is in a
good spot we've got a ton of young
talent I mean all that said yes I think
there's a couple things that need be
tweaked the biggest conversations we've
been having that are negative are about
the shift how to adjust to that yes pace
of play we talked about and the pitch
clock you know every player that I
talked to has a different view on it but
if you look at Myer League baseball they
have the pitch clock in now and guys are
used to it so those kids are getting
called in the big leagues and they're
looking around for its clock it's not
there anymore so I I think with some
things that can be tweaked and
throughout history of all the sports
where was basketball they put in a
three-point line you know if it was
football they continue to change their
rules because you want after you want
you want scoring you want action and so
that's what we got to get back to what's
your bet what's your prediction for this
year Harold coming in what do you got
you know what I had the Astros in the
World Series and I had them playing
against the Cubs and they're both off to
a slow start but we'll see I still think
at the end of the day you've got I think
the Angels are gonna be better the
Mariners are showing that they're better
than they
then I thought that would be the
surprise club that I saw this spring
where the Nationals even though Harper's
gone
I think the Nats are gonna be right
there I love them the National League
East it's a beast yeah Mets are better
the Phillies are really good that
braiser good club and and who I talked
about already the Nationals so those
four are gonna be tough to be yeah we
had Leiter on opening day and he had
Astros Cardinals nobody had card think
Solomon spring yeah yeah and Adam and
Andrew Miller with that club as well so
those two guys change team around
Goldschmidt is like he he is in the
dictionary the photograph of a cardinal
right he's truly the old Schmidt is a
st. Louis Cardinals yeah as the day is
long and I tell you what Bryce Harper
looks like a filly he's fitting in great
there I'm seeing the Bryce Harper I knew
when he was like 17 or 18 on fire
excited about going to the ballpark
yelling and screaming I thought the home
run he hit and he came back got the
curtain cause at that game Saturday in
Philly last weekend and the curtain call
most guys come out tip the cap you know
he came out yelling and screaming it was
so cool well he went to a sixer game
last night with Wentz right Yeah right
now yeah he and Carson Wentz they're
just so the Young Turks of the Philly
sports scene paying homage to the Sixers
the young team in a way of the Philly
sports scene he wants to get entrenched
in there and and then that the bat flip
I guess it's not surprising that the
Nats fans would boo him but did they not
know how much deferred money he was
offered I mean is that is that not I
guess I mean it doesn't matter it really
does it I mean he left their club and
that's all anybody who's a loyal fan
booked it that way and if it was he's
signed for less money to go somewhere
they'd still be upset with him which i
think is great that's that's what sports
are about the bat flip was epic it was
good and I'm not really a big bat flip
guy but in that moment it's kind of like
okay I struck out before you had your
say now here's my say bat flip and the
ball went like it was the home run derby
yeah it's good stuff it's
it's good to see you sir all right my
man here let me know you're out in Los
Angeles yes sir come a nice little edge
wow these coasts you know what I like it
it's just that's just my old my old
stomping grounds where I was born and
raised in the city and it's great the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience